[Music]
good idea welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight the president is holding a rally
this evening in Panama City Florida
we'll go to it live when he begins
speaking one thing we're gonna be
watching for is whether the president
responds to the seismic story that broke
last night on cable news in case you
weren't watching CNN at 10 p.m. here's
how they summarized it
it's a CNN tonight I'm Don Lemon are you
listening the President of the United
States is a fraud and a con man holy
smokes it sounds like a big development
what happened the president get caught
running a Nigerian phone scam has he
been selling Bitcoin did he spend two
full years pretending that the Russian
collision hoax was real nope nothing
that sleazy last night the New York
Times revealed that more than 30 years
ago some of trumps businesses lost quite
a bit of money because of that he paid
no federal income taxes for eight of the
ten years for which they had data
unfortunately this is a pretty common
way to account just last year for
example some of the biggest companies in
the world paid no federal income taxes
for exactly the same reason that list
would include Amazon Delta Airlines
Chevron and General Motors seenin hasn't
said a lot about that they were too busy
gloating over Trump's taxes from the
Reagan administration ladies and
gentlemen introducing mr. Don Lemon you
know what they say about gambling casino
gambling right the house always wins
well not always
none of it's a Trump casino because I'm
good enough smart enough and doggone
people love me
Oh Don LeMond is easily amused and he
was thrilled last night when the whole
point of your network is to attack a
single person this is a major story from
his shadowy lair hidden high above the
newsroom CNN secretive dwarf King
slithered to the intercom and summoned
his minions from across the cable empire
they gathered at his beckoning each with
talking points ready he lost more than
double the next biggest loser in this
country so he's literally the biggest
loser his losses were more than double
the next biggest loser in the country
does this to you explain why he doesn't
doesn't want anyone to have this
information that he was such a loser
he calls people losers and he has such
disdain and and yet he was literally the
biggest loser in the country Trump lost
money what's a good thing CNN is on that
story otherwise nobody would have
guessed that Donald Trump had financial
problems in the early 1990s except
people who were alive then or people who
have internet access now 30 years ago
Trump's personal debt crisis was
national news inside his wallet
Trump papers revealed huge debt read the
tabloids Trump in a slump even David
Letterman mocked Trump with a top 10
list top ten signs that Donald Trump is
in trouble
in the end Donald Trump recovered he
made the disaster part of his brand in
fact he wrote a book about it called art
of the comeback when he launched his
reality show The Apprentice he bragged
about all of this
about 13 years ago I was seriously in
trouble
I was billions of dollars in debt but I
fought back and I won big
so in other words what we learned last
night wasn't really news what is news is
that you can steal someone's private tax
information put it on television and
nobody even pauses or asks whether
that's a good idea much less an invasion
of privacy
are those the rules now well according
to Democrats yes they are the rules
lawmakers in New York are preparing
legislation that would force the release
of Trump's tax returns but why step
there how about his medical records how
about his internet search history how
about his texts or transcripts of his
phone calls why not and if people who
don't like Donald Trump can get that
information about him what about those
of us who don't like CNN can we get Don
LeMans tax returns what about Jeff
Zucker's internet search history
that'd be compelling seriously why not
what's the limit is there a limit
[Music]